hi i'm alvin and today i'll be teaching
you how to make my magic chocolate ball
recipe
[Music]
so you guys might have may or may not
have already seen this recipe on the
tasty channel a couple of times i did it
behind the scenes of it
[Music]
yikes it looks like all the chocolate
collected
this
giant like
giant like block
chunk but i really want to give you guys
more instructions and more of a story on
how to make this happen so the the
inspiration for this recipe comes from a
lot of new york restaurants were serving
it at the time it was pretty popular it
was all over instagram and i was like
man i want to figure out how to do that
for this recipe you actually do not want
to use milk chocolate you want to use
good chocolate because you want it to be
firm you want it to be snappy you don't
want any of those extra sugars or other
things they put into candy bars that can
help kind of make the ball a little soft
so you really want to get nice chocolate
for this you want to melt your chocolate
but you do not want to overheat it it
will cause it to coagulate so the most
important thing is that you need to find
the right containers or molds for the
recipe i use refillable ornaments that i
just got online you can find them on
amazon basically they're these clear
plastic ball ornaments and depending on
how big you want the chocolate ball to
be it can be anywhere from four inches
in diameter to around eight inches you
really just you know need to figure out
what size you're gonna make and who
you're making it for that's probably the
most important thing and make sure you
get multiple because you're gonna maybe
crack some of the balls and then the
trick is to pour that amount of
chocolate into the ornament close it
really really really tight and you
really just want to like hold it and
press it so you do not let any of the
chocolate escape from the edges and just
slowly rotate it but you also you don't
want to move too slow sometimes what
happens is that if you rotate it and it
doesn't coat the whole ball it'll cool
down before it even coats the whole
thing and this is kind of hard so you
might just be like kind of doing this
weird you know ballerina dance where you
hold it and look at it you know
if you watch the behind tasty i'd do
this like 300 times
[Music]
so you kind of have to do that and watch
it and kind of tap it a little bit to
get it into the right spots after that
they go in the freezer and when they go
in the freezer you want to make sure
that they're level that they won't just
roll around everywhere and every like
two minutes or so until they're set you
want to actually check them make like i
would say like like you know four to six
of the chocolate balls put them in the
freezer expect some of them to break
because you really just need one and
the key to opening it is to really just
make sure that at first you use your
hands to kind of hold it and warm warm
it a little bit so you kind of see like
this huge thing sometimes it'll crack
sometimes it won't it really is a game
of luck you know we're putting it on a
heated sort of bowl to kind of rub so
that the chocolate melts and you kind of
get this hole for it to sit and stand on
to fill it with anything you want after
that kind of put whatever it is on the
plate um the key here is to keep the
plate the ball and anything
cold so if you're using ice cream keep
it in the freezer until the last second
of using berries keep them in the fridge
if you're using a brownie or a cake also
keep it in the freezer keep your plate
in the freezer you do not want the ball
to melt before anything happens once you
take that out you kind of assemble one
brownie or a cake kind of put some
berries around it i like strawberries i
like blueberries you can fill it with
whatever you want honestly and you kind
of put the ice cream scoop on top of
that and then you put the ball you kind
of want to snuggle it over the sides if
it's not fitting you can either you know
shave off some more chocolate take out
some of the berries you just want to
make sure that when the ball is on the
plate it looks like nothing is
underneath it it's just a chocolate ball
under a plate because that's the
surprise don't worry if there's like
little cracks between the plate and the
ball itself just run a ring
berries around it it covers up most of
the problems that's what i pretty much
did and
that is your chocolate ball that is
almost ready to serve the last and final
bit is going to be the really hot
ganache that kind of goes on it and
turns it from chocolate ball to magic
chocolate ball so the chocolate ganache
is just even parts milk and cream you
are pretty much ready to serve so what
you'll do is you'll serve the dessert to
whoever you're making it for import in a
circular motion over the top and then
boom that's it from there you got money
raining everywhere horns fanfare is
playing what actually happens is that
the chocolate is going to melt the ball
and cause a waterfall effect where first
it'll make a little bit of a hole where
it first melts and then the entire thing
should theoretically crumble and
collapse in a really beautiful melty way
and the walls will fall away revealing
every single beautiful thing that you
put inside hopefully it's colorful
berries with ice cream and cake maybe
it's a wedding ring i don't know is that
how i'm gonna propose maybe don't worry
about it
if my future fiance is watching out
there
i should probably change up the method
huh but i think if you really are
dedicated to it and want to give up some
time it can be done and you can achieve
that restaurant looking effect without
having to go out
[Music]
you